bonsoir et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france pour emmanuel
macron on l'a entendu au début de cette
édition a depuis à erbil discuter des
évacuations avec les talibans ça n'est
pas les reconnaître david rigoulet roze
c'est important que le président
français apporte cette précision
oui s'il n'y a pas que lui qui a apporté
cette précision les buzz pour fait
également de manière générale il ya un
an un attentisme prudent et on va dire
aussi un réalisme géopolitique c'est une
donnée factuel aujourd'hui il est allé
les talibans ont pris le pouvoir en
afghanistan qu'on veuille ou non qu'on
regrette ou non et donc la question
c'est de savoir si on discute ou pas
avec eux pour pour arriver à un certain
nombre d'objectifs
avec les nouveaux paramètres donc
d'ailleurs les français françois richier
qui était ambassadeur ancien ambassadeur
à kaboul effectivement à a commencé des
discussions à doha avec le bureau
politique justement des talibans comme
l'ont fait d'autres précédemment donc il
ya de la part du comité international
activement la nécessité de discuter ça
veut pas dire qu'on est que les deux
parties sont en situation amical mais il
ya un principe de réalité qui impose
jean luc racine donc ça montre aussi que
le dialogue avec les taliban et de toute
façon incontournable est ce que selon
vous il ya d'autres solutions pour la
communauté internationale
n'ont de toute façon il n'y a pas
d'autre solution
bien entendu et ça a été dit
confirmer
parler avec les talibans négocier avec
eux parce qu'en l'occurrence c'est de ça
dont il s'agit quand on parle de
poursuivre les évacuations
ce n'est absolument pas reconnaître
l'état islamique dans le moment aucun
pays ne l'a reconnu lui même le pakistan
quand on sait les liens traditionnels
avec les talibans a pris comme posture
de dire
rhô ne feront pas de reconnaissance de
l'émirat islamique en dehors d'un
certain consensus international mais le
principe de réalité impose
de discuter avec les nouveaux maîtres de
kaboul c'est absolument inévitable
et de toute façon on sait bien que que
ce soit moscou que ce soit téhéran que
je sois pékin les grandes puissances
régionales
voisine de l'afghanistan
entretenu et entretiennent des liens
avec les talibans depuis des années
avec le royaume uni on l'a vu emmanuel
macron et mettez donc cette idée de
créer une zone protégée pour permettre
de poursuivre les opérations
d'évacuation il avait estimé ce projet
comme totalement réalisable mais les
talibans n'en veulent pas ils estiment
que cela n'est pas nécessaire david
rigoulet roze qu'est-ce que ça démontre
que les talibans ne veulent de toute
façon plus de présence d' influence
étrangère sur le sol afghan oui c'est le
principe de la ligne rouge relative à la
date du 31 août
je vois que le départ définitif des
américains partie des occidentaux en
général les américains particulier donc
il n'y a pas forcément d'ailleurs il ya
des tensions au sein de la gouvernance
talibane n'y a pas forcément une une
ligne tout à fait homogène notamment
avec des gones négociateurs à doha comme
stanekzai qui est beaucoup plus on va
dire police et vis-à-vis de la
communauté internationale et d'autre à
kaboul manifestement il y avait l'idée
du président macro effectivement par
delà de la date butoir de maintenir la
possibilité en fait de poursuivre
certaines évacuations de on va dire
d'afghans qui n'avait pas bu bénéficier
d'explications donc ça fait le ca fait
l'objet de négociations
mais de toute façon avec un projet de
résolution qui serait présentée
conjointement avec les britanniques mais
on peut quand même s'interroger sur la
viabilité ce type de projet parce que à
partir du moment les américains seront
partis l'idée d'une ces exodes qui
seraient éventuellement sous supervision
de l'onu reste sujette à caution en
matière de sécurisation opérationnel
c'est pas des casques bleus de l'onu qui
pourrait sécuriser l'espace
ces exemples potentiel a fortiori s'il
ya des réticences en plus des aliments
jean luc racine vous êtes d'accord avec
un avis des rigoles et rose c'est une
proposition qui n'est de toute façon pas
viable
disons que
elle pose aussi un problème aux talibans
réalité parce que
l'idée de londres et de paris qui sera
mis sur la table demain au conseil de
sécurité et donc on verra quelle sera la
position de moscou et de pékin sur cette
affaire
pour les talibans c'est un peu délicat
parce que la quête d'une nouvelle
virginité si j'ose dire la quête
d'un meilleur statut international
n'irai pas très bien avec un refus net
franc et massif de ce que serait une
initiative de l'onu si le conseil de
sécurité
accepter la proposition franco
britannique après que le porte parole
des taliban et dès aujourd'hui ça n'est
pas une proposition acceptable eh bien
nous verrons mais de toute façon se
posera effectivement comme ça vient
d'être dit la question de la capacité à
maintenir la sécurité
sur les reports et autour de l'aéroport
de kaboul et on sait très bien que une
mission de casques bleus ne s'improvise
pas en quelques jours donc au delà de la
limite du 31 d'autant plus qu'un bon
nombre de pays ont déjà dans la france
d'ailleurs mais qui n'est pas la seule
ont déjà terminé leur évacuation
la question va être très sensible mais
on en sera déjà beaucoup plus demain
pour savoir si cette proposition
reçoit l'approbation de dessin condroz
permanent voire de la totalité des
membres du conseil de sécurité on voit
bien que les talibans cherchent à
redorer leur blason à privilégier la
diplomatie c'est donc uniquement une
posture selon vous stéphane rozès
histoire de rassurer de rassurer sur
place mais aussi à l'étranger peut-être
qu'on les laisse faire
dany voléro spam
on l'espère il ya une stratégie de
communication incontestablement qui est
assez élaboré céder ôta les gants sont
pas de ce point de vue là les plus les
mêmes que ceux des années 90 2000 qui
faisait fi de tout effectivement de
toute stratégie vis-à-vis de l'extérieur
là c'est pas le cas parce qu'il ya
l'enjeu crucial pour eux aujourd'hui
d'une reconnaissance internationale
c'est un au fondamentalisme et qui est
fondamentalement islamo nationaliste
dont qui a besoin de cette
reconnaissance ne serait ce que pour
pouvoir assurer la pérennité de leur
gouvernance parce que là il sait que de
toute façon il ya les horizons des
difficultés économiques qui se profile
il ya la nécessité d'une aide extérieure
évidemment puisqu'il n'y a pas d'argent
il ya la question de faire tourner un
état c'est plus uniquement une guerrière
donc c'est tout à fait différent il ya
aussi un principe de réalité pour les
talibans donc le problème c'est que
l'adn et aliments sur le fond n'a pas
changé c'est à dire que et c'est là
effectivement ce pas se faire
d'illusions mais il pourra y avoir des
ajustements
d'une certaine manière avec une société
talibane a à plusieurs vitesses c'est à
dire très très archaïque dans les
campagnes et puis avec des ajustements
dans les villes parce qu'ils se sont
heurtés aux chocs sociologique de la
modernité est donc là il y aura des
ajustements à faire justement parce que
ils ont besoin aussi de cette interface
avec l'international qui impliquent un
certain nombre de compromis relatif de
leur part qu'ils seront aussi demandé de
l'autre côté aux autres interlocuteurs
d'ailleurs avec l'attentât de l'aéroport
de kaboul mais aussi la frappe de
défense aérienne des etats-unis
après l'évocation de menace imminente la
branche locale donc du groupe terroriste
état islamique on peut dire qu'elle
domine les inquiétudes que peut-on
espérer des talibans face à cette menace
jean luc racine
pour que les talibans menées depuis des
années maintenant
des combats contre
les djihadistes internationaux si les
dires de l'état islamique au hasard
puisque c'est le nom que qui a été
choisi celui le nom anciens de la région
afghane et de ses marges
en même temps il ya évidemment un vrai
défi pour la gouvernance talibans pas
seulement parce que la communauté
internationale attend d'eux est
particulièrement moscou puisque moscou a
prend bien garde à ce que un état
islamique au khorassan qui se
renforceraient ne viennent pas déborder
vers les pays d'asie centrale de la même
façon la chine leur a demandé de faire
en sorte que les militants ouigours qui
pourrait être dont l'état islamique ogre
hassan ou en dehors de l'état islamique
ne puisse pas reprendre de la vigueur
contre la chine dans le think tank donc
c'est une un vrai problème pour eux
d'autant plus que historiquement n'a vu
il des talibans pakistanais et des
talibans afghans
rejoindre l'état islamique y avait un
foyer assez notable aux marges de la
frontière entre l'afghanistan et le
pakistan dont la province de nangahar et
en même temps ils savent très bien que
dès l'accord de doha et emmanuel macron
mais comme beaucoup d'autres l'a redit
aujourd'hui
ils seront jugés par la communauté
internationale aussi sur la capacité à
juguler l'état islamique est plus
délicat pour eux vu les liens anciens
établi entre talibans et al qaïda on va
faire en sorte que le qaïda ne
deviennent pas une menace majeure dans
le pays au-delà du pays
david rigoulet roze on peut s'attendre à
une lutte des talibans contre des jetons
afghanistan ça fait partie des enjeux
des talibans pour avoir cette
reconnaissance internationale
cette lutte elle a déjà lieu
depuis plusieurs années il y avait une
convergence objectif sur certaines
opérations entre même d'armes et
afghanes et les talibans pour réduire
les dires les les fiefs de l'état
islamique que ce soit dans le nord du
de la vague et distant ou à la frontière
justement afghano pakistanaise il ya un
tournant c'est là dès 2018 ce qui est
une bataille d'effectivement dans la
province de jowzjan et qui a qui a
amoindri les capacités opérationnelles
des talibans par l'ondé de l'état
islamique au point d'ailleurs que les
activistes certains actifs sur préférés
seront de gouvernement à l'époque j'ai
plutôt que de tomber sous sous le joug
des talibans et puis les fiefs
traditionnels qui avait besoin de kunar
mangas etc se sont progressivement
réduits même s'ils sont plus n'existant
pas inexistant encore aujourd'hui mais
enfin en tout cas il ya eu une
conversion sous forme de terrorisme
urbain plutôt de la part de l'état
islamique du khorassan on l'a vu avec la
multiplication des attentats dont dans
les villes et notamment à kaboul donc
incontestablement pour les talibans
c'est un problème il ya il n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté par rapport à l'état
islamique il s'agit de décisions prises
ont
fait monsieur racine à moscou en juillet
pour éradiquer la possibilité même de
l'installation des tests chimiques en
revanche effectivement pour al qaeda
c'est plus compliqué parce
qu'historiquement il ya déjà des liens
matrimoniaux vidéo logique et puis il ya
le réseau haqqani qui est très proche
d'al qaïda et qui fait partie de la
mouvance talibane et là on peut penser
qu'il va y avoir des tensions dans la
nouvelle gouvernance talibane entre eux
on va dire la normalisation politique
assurée par le mollah baradar par
exemple et puis les chefs militaires qui
sont pas forcément sur une ligne on va
dire
plus modérée merci beaucoup d'avis de
rigoler rose pour toutes ces précisions
je rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en
chef de la revue orient stratégique et
merci à vous jean luc racine directeur
émérite de recherche au cnrs et
chercheur senior asia center merci
entier